all right we all love living here in
southern nevada right of course we do
but how do we bring more tech jobs to
our area that is the goal behind an
entrepreneur's effort who says now is
the time what he's planning to do to
entice the movers and shakers to our
area
i've always loved vegas eventually i was
going to come here teddy leo just didn't
realize it would be so soon not too long
ago as the official ambassador for
governor gavin newsom he was tasked with
bringing economic opportunity to
california but kovitt and a rising crime
in san francisco spurred him to move his
wife and newborn here and now it's all
about las vegas the end game is to
transform vegas the ceo of nexrep teddy
is also a founding member of governor
steve sislek's startup and venture
council with the goal to diversify las
vegas make us a tech hub insulate us
from the ups and downs of the economy
and provide better jobs for people he
says too many billionaires are moving
from california to miami and austin when
they should be moving here we've got the
tax benefits we've got the economic
benefits we've got the sports teams that
are coming in we've got formula we also
have more infrastructure than we did 10
years ago teddy and a handful of other
leaders have a summit scheduled for
september inviting entrepreneurs and
billionaires to showcase all the
positives of southern nevada i think
that if we show people
what vegas like the real vegas
like the non-touristy strip part of
vegas
is like then that's pretty powerful the
group will start at allegiance stadium
then head to red rock visit exclusive
communities as well as private schools
and a goal is to convert some of these
people
to be residents and to move their
spouses their families their company
their employees and create
jobs and so far some of the confirmed
attendees include one of the founders of
yeezy eugene kim and kevin lynn one of
the founders of twitch